der vater emotionen kamen von der
anfangs erzählt
ich wollte aber es gab keine möglichkeit
zum fahrzeug verlor
wir müssen in argentinien bliebe ja hier
lieber weil um eventuelle zurück erhält
oder mit dem schiff bis buenos aires und
verdeckt weiteres schiff zu nach
geschützt und jetzt einfach gebaut
mecano dass ich unmöglich sie unmöglich
unter einem ort namens el dorado hatte
sich die familie folgt die irgendwie
etwas anderes vorgestellt als sie sich
1936 entschloss die stadt bern zu
verlassen um hierher auszuwandern
was also wenn das leben nichts zu tun
haben will mit unseren träumen
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
dass sie ihre reise in die neue heimat
nicht bergauf sondern steil bergab
führen würde wurde der familie folgte
erst klar als in argentinien angekommen
war und es kein zurück mehr gab
in absolut keine idee was wir sie
während sie konnte das gar nicht
vorstellen weil in der schweiz 20 cent
es ist ein wunderbares land da machst
alles gute
dann sind sie hat aber den mir dass ich
ihr nur wollt ich komme nun dass nun da
ich absolut
die familie freut die war in der provinz
misiones gelandet im nordosten des
landes nach den wasserfällen von iguazú
[Musik]
am anfang hätte geschenk kann denn
butter oder bisher hier geht dabei um
das wasser reichen
ich sag mal so wie max k
hunderte die gläser die drucksachen
forward stufe waren nicht so viel hitze
im halten
heute haben keine andere wahl als sich
durchzubeißen und ihre träume dem leben
irgendwie aufzudrängen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vanessa friedrich ist elviras tochter
sie machte das wovon ihr großvater
zeitlebens geträumt hatte war sie
verließ argentinien und wanderte in die
schweiz aus heute leitet sie die mensa
der uni zürich
wieso sind sie dieses spiel so ein jahr
2000 nach ja damals hat es nicht
wirklich eine möglichkeit gehabt mich
weiter beruflich zu entwickeln und da
ich keine last mini l und sein monster
habe ich mich entschieden haben zu gehen
ursprünglich war spanien gesagt und
dabei wenig sein der schweiz gelangt und
wie quarz ihnen ja langsam auch nicht
einfach wenn die ganze familie so weit
weg ist und sich ein freundeskreis
aufzubauen
beruflich sehr wichtig ist natürlich
schwierig und ja mit der zeit geben sich
die sache und wir mittlerweile mit ganz
wurde
[Musik]
vanessa friedlich hat in argentinien
einen bachelor in
betriebswirtschaftslehre gemacht und
musste feststellen dass sich die zeiten
geändert haben
heute ist die schweiz ein land der
möglichkeiten mehr fleißig ist und es zu
etwas bringen will dem stehen hier alle
türen offen
nur wärme dürfte es sein findet sie vor
allem auch zwischenmenschlich sind
schweizer nicht so oft nicht so wie in
argentinischen erklären dass es ganz
einfach gesagt gerade von der begrüßung
ausschuss war sich sofort mal begrüßt
jede mit einem kuss sofort und da ich
lese handschrift mal dass die freuen
sich ergibt dose und das merkt man
sicherlich schwierig oder diese nicht an
zu sagen dass wir nicht gewählt die lage
im kino
[Musik]
andrés friedrich ist vanessas blut der
montierte sechs jahre lang küchen in der
schweiz im vergangenen oktober hielt er
es nicht mehr aus und zog zurück nach
argentinien
[Musik]
lassen sie einen chor meisten vermissten
die musik wie sie sind
kollegen
kollegen im wald machen
neben
dafür muss man schaffen
bisher noch nie
am meisten
seine arbeit rege wille weiterhin zahlen
ohne eine rente aus der schweiz könnte
der ruhestand in argentinien nämlich der
einst bitter werden
die schweizer honorarkonsulin mission
ist maja schwierig berät ihn wir
beitrags lücken vermeiden kann ein rad
kommt indes zu spät in der schweiz zu
bleiben denn argentinien schlittert
einmal mehr in eine wirtschaftskrise
ich glaube in dem moment musst du viele
große krise hat sorgen linie ist es nur
thomas für tschudow villa wo arbeite ich
jetzt nicht die meiste was gemacht hat
wir sehen jetzt dass 16 träger sie hosen
und so einfach
[Musik]
dank der guten beziehungen seines vaters
hat andrés friedrich nach zwei monaten
eine stelle als außendienstmitarbeiter
gefunden er verkauft hunde und
katzenfutter
muss ich mit einer der enorm dass ich
bin viel unterwegs kenne viele leute die
da an der sache so das gefühl ich fahre
gern auto
[Musik]
einen fixen lohn hat er nicht mehr
erlebt zu 100 prozent von provisionen um
halbwegs über die runden zu kommen
arbeitet der sechs tage pro woche
nicht selten 15 stunden am tag
seine freunde die er in der schweiz so
vermisst hat sieht er kaum keine zeit
[Musik]
vanessa friedlich arbeitet fünf tage pro
woche und kompensiert sämtliche
überstunden so bleibt viel zeit für
freunde alle zloty muss sich erika und
zwar vier gehören sind in allen dingen
zum beispiel vorstellen
er bezieht fan ist eine schweizer
wohlbekannt nützt nur hat damit sparen
überhaupt kein optisches kurt meeres
dank marcus heiss gegessen wird und
andere verstehen eure samstag
argentinien russland die wir fliegen
will und kann nächste woche auf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sie ist man hier bereits dass die
schweiz zurück in der folge
jetzt bin ich schon da
[Musik]
andrés friedrich kehrte in ein land
zurück das ende 2015 einen neuen
präsidenten bekam
seit mauritius amtsantritt hat sich der
wert des argentinischen peso gegenüber
dem dollar halbiert
heriberto friedlich ist andress und wann
es als vater und elvira lehmann
er ist ein nachkomme von deutsch polen
die 1938 nach argentinien ausgewandert
sind
dank harter arbeit braucht es die
familie innerhalb von drei generationen
zu 78 hektar land die er heute
bewirtschaftet seine familie ist die
mittelstand angekommen den
wirtschaftlichen aufstieg sei alles
untergeordnet worden sagt friedrich
solange er denken könne habe ich sein
leben aus arbeit bestanden
sie haben bayer praktisch und sehr wenig
sehr wenig weil wir hier sehr allein man
und wenig möglichkeiten hatten zum zum
fortgehen weil man keinen kein die
möglichkeit hatten wir hatten früher
dann ein seite konnte mein vater ein
wagen kaufen dann sind wir mal mit dem
wagen im dorf gefahren und es war alles
[Musik]
aus jugendlicher träumte herbert
friedrich davon
dieser enge zu entkommen davon eines
tages die große weite welt zu sehen
[Musik]
wenn ich heute 20 jahre hätte das werde
ich machen war keine leere andere länder
kennenzulernen und andere sitten das
werde ich tun
wo würden sie zu einer reise nach europa
europa deutschland schweiz
[Musik]
denn
dass sie ihre tochter vanessa
ermöglichen konnten in die heimat ihrer
vorfahren zurückzukehren erfüllt die
eltern mit genugtuung mit der
möglichkeit dass es hier so gut gefallen
könnte dass sie bleiben will hat
allerdings niemand gerechnet
genauso wenig hatte ihr vorfahre paul
volk die 1936 damit gerechnet dass es
noch schlimmer kommen konnte als im
berner loren quartier wo er aus
pferdeschwänzen bürsten gemacht und
gedacht hatte die kinder und
kindeskinder sollten es einmal besser
haben
[Musik]
das war so die zwischen erster und
zweiter weltkrieg und das hat sich
rumgesprochen dass in argentinien damals
reserven geld konnte man sehr viel land
kaufen und das hat viele leute anlocken
harry dinos zusammen
die schweiz wollte ihr packt damals
loswerden arme schlucker arbeitslose und
kleinkriminelle mit falschen
versprechungen und finanziellen anreizen
wurde ihnen die überfahrt schmackhaft
gemacht
in argentinien waren sie herzlich
willkommen denn die regierung braucht
die leute die ihr land urbar machten und
anfingen ein export wirtschaft
aufzubauen
[Musik]
also wurden auswanderungswillige von
spezialisierten agenturen nach buenos
aires gelockt von wo aus sie aufs ganze
land verteilt wurden allerdings nicht
ohne ihnen vorher ihre ganzen
ersparnisse abzunehmen so dass sie
unmöglich wieder abreisen konnten
[Musik]
ein kleines ortsmuseum versucht die
erinnerung an die erste einwanderer
generation wachzuhalten an menschen wie
elvira friedlich projektes vater für ihn
sei die auswanderung bis ins hohe alter
ein trauma geblieben sagt seine tochter
wirklich angekommen sei er nie in der
neuen heimat was sind denn sexy wo im
fall arcandor in argentinien
was ihn wegfalle hätte ich das öfter
verspricht machen organisiert und das
macht natürlich dass ich einmal im jahr
und nach einem aufstand machen das eher
schweigsame räume und könne sich
erzählen was sie machen und wo sehen sie
um ihr geld deshalb im zelt falle diese
tradition hatten die nachfahren bis
heute lebendig der ist der august gehört
weiterhin zu den höhepunkten im kalender
[Musik]
inzwischen gibt es sogar eine plastik
dass wir einen schweizer platz
ein treffpunkt für die nachkommen von
schweizer auswanderern und für herüber
durch friedrich seine erfolgreiche
integration in die gemeinde der exil
schweizer wurde 2001 mit dem schweizer
bürgerrecht belohnt gemeinsam wird nun
bereits die nächste bundesfeier geplant
könnte sich vorstellen die schweiz
locker weg foto mission ist verlor
einfach hier alles lasse und nach der
schätzung könnte sich schnell integriert
in der schweiz und trotzdem sind sie
weiterhin stolze schweizerin
trotzdem bin ich stolz er mag am imba
banal und papa das fühlt sich alles
und deshalb vom papa gelernt haben sie
in der ferne freilich noch etwas anderes
nämlich dass die familie zusammenhalten
muss egal was kommt
das hat auch vanessa friedrich
verinnerlicht und es macht ihr leben
nicht einfacher
[Musik]
familie verloren haben die eltern das
locker oder ist das thema nicht ganz
locker aber sie wissen dass wenn sie
mich brauchen ich bin immer für denen da
und ich bin auch bereit alles zu geben
und für mich sah zu sein aber ich muss
auch in lebenden mieter leben und ich
kann nicht ständig nur an denen denken
ich muss auch auf wkg lohr der unter den
lehrern macht oder wenn die eltern zum
beispiel auf 10 flaggt werden könnte
sich vorstellen dass sie weg könnte
schweiz orientiere betreuen darf
andere sagen nein so wie hoch wachsen
bin ist das eine selbstverständlichkeit
bei uns das ist quasi das ich meine
eltern steht klasse wenn ich das nicht
gemacht hat
aber es würde zu machen das berichtet
eine machen
[Musik]
sonntag im hause friedlich verlief
friedlich widmet sich seinem asado arche
kino seine frau frittierte weil man ja
alles so wie es bereits bei ihren eltern
und großeltern gewesen ist gegen falls
fast alles
[Musik]
es ist nicht einfach sagt also ja doch
dich jetzt sowie fort- und wenn sie mal
zurückkommt für ganz oder bloß auf zu
april sonne samt man sich quälen andrés
friedlich hat sich nach seiner rückkehr
nach argentinien eine eigene wohnung
genommen dass er seine eltern jeweils am
sonntag besucht ist jedoch bis auf
weiteres selbstverständlich dass sich
die kinder zu sehen sie als individuen
also einig verstehen nicht mehr als teil
eines wir ist wie die eltern nicht
einfach zu akzeptieren
die stimmung ist auch schon besser
gewesen und sonntäglichen familientisch
unser wunsch ist mit meiner frau dass
wir unsere familie weiter so
zusammenhalten wie immer passiert
[Musik]
sind alle glücklich heute schweiz nicht
was man auch die glückliche die schweiz
das wirke sich mein leben selbst geklebt
verarbeitet man deren selbst in der hand
habe und er sich selber darüber
entscheiden
ich nehme mich da so beträgt viele
vorgegangen in israel ist dass man sehr
viel von den eltern abhängig
schon das gefühl habe ich sagen das
macht sie ganz frisch
manchmal ist es zeit den zauber eines
neuen anfangs zu vertrauen
[Musik]
und manchmal müssen die die
zurückbleiben versuchen die eigenen
sorgen zu verbergen
damit andere glücklich sein können
wenn sie nicht glücklich hier ich wenn
ich da was soll ich machen was sie ja
nicht abwenden
ich freu mich aufnehmen
[Musik]